-Come on. Come on.
I'm so happy
you guys are all here.
-We're happy to be here.
-But before we get into things,
I don't want to spoil
anything for people
who haven't watched
the finale yet.
So if you don't want to hear
a spoiler, plug your ears now.
Okay? No.
You guys know what happened.
Yeah, yeah.
Mai, congratulations.
You won "Squid Game:
The Challenge."
-Thank you so much. Yes.
-This is fantastic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What does it feel like?
What has today -- What has today
been like for you?
-Liberating and I feel like...
-Is it liberating?
-Yes. It's like --
Because the burden
has just lifted off my shoulder.
-Because you couldn't
tell anyone what happened.
-Exactly. Yeah.
-No family. Nothing.
-Except my husband.
-Yeah, just your husband.
Explain to me
what goes into this
because I know "Squid Game"
comes out,
it's a giant hit on Netflix.
Love it. And then they go,
"We're actually going to make
that show into an actual
reality competition."
I go, "How is this possible?"
And they did it in
a fantastic way. It was so good.
But you get the -- Do you see
an audition somewhere?
Do you go, "Hey,
I want to get into this"?
What'd you think?
-Just saw an ad online
and applied.
-And you thought that,
"I could do what the show..."
Have you ever seen "Squid Game"?
-So, I'd never actually
seen the show
until after I got casted.
-Is that correct?
-Yeah.
-How about you?
Did you see the show before?
Did you see it?
-I saw it. I was a huge fan.
Um, I clearly
don't value my life.
-No, I mean --
Seriously, obviously,
no one's going to die,
but I mean, like,
they did it so well.
When you watch,
you'll see how they did it.
It was just perfectly done.
Do you go into it and go,
"Okay, I got to start
working on some strategies"?
Is there strategies?
-Um, there's no real strategy.
I mean, a lot of it is luck.
I got casted three days
before I flew out,
so there was basically
no time to prepare.
And a lot of it
was just friendships.
-Really?
-Yeah.
-For me, it's, uh --
There's a balance of 50/50.
There's chance,
and there's strategy.
And I did not prepare for it.
But I did watch the show twice,
you know, just to get
the idea of the games
and the mentality of the players
on the TV show.
-And what'd your husband say?
He said you should do it?
-Yeah, he's the one
who encouraged me to do it.
-Oh, my gosh!
Did you -- I would --
-he apparently doesn't love me.
-No. Yeah. He's so...
Well, he definitely
loves you now.
Okay? Yeah. Hello!
I mean, it's a lot of money,
by the way.
-Yes.
-It's one of the largest
in the history of reality shows.
$4.56 million?
-But do you know Uncle Sam?
This is not Uncle Sam.
Do you know Uncle Sam?
He's gonna take half of it.
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's still a good...
What are you gonna do
with the money?
-I want to do my cause,
you know.
I believe in the passion
about charity work.
So the three things are climate,
animals, and underprivileged.
And I want to expand
that horizon.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Good for you. That's awesome.
I mean, you're all great people.
You're also -- You're in a band.
-Yes. Uh, my new band,
Six Ways to Saturday.
We just dropped a single today.
It's called "Fantasy."
Check us out.
-Yeah. Alright. Good.
It's out today?
-Yeah. Out today.
-Yeah.
-And I can't help but notice,
but you have a beautiful beard.
You're going into the beard
kind of business.
-Yes, yeah,
I have a gender-inclusive
beard-care brand, uh,
caring for facial hair,
that anybody can --
anybody can grow facial hair.
They don't have to identify
as, you know, a man.
And a lot of the beard-care
brands out there
right now are just --
kind of narrow focus
to, you know, a Viking,
you're a lumberjack,
you're a warrior.
And, you know,
beards are beautiful.
Beards make you beautiful.
-Yeah.
That's fantastic. Very good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It makes you want to grow
a beard now, right?
-It does. Yeah.
I wanted to ask you --
Because out of all the games
that you played,
of course,
they're ones from the show.
The red light, green light one,
which was the first episode,
which was frightening.
And then the last game,
it was rock, paper, scissors
that you won all this money on.
Rock, paper, scissors.
-I know, right?
-That is how you won
all this money.
Out of every game you played,
that is the one I go,
"Oh, my gosh."
-I couldn't ask
for a better game.
-Did you know
that was going to be...
-No.
-No. No one knows that.
But do you have a strategy when
it goes to rock paper, scissors?
-Well, I have a concept
of just playing
throughout my childhood
and my adult life.
And so I have a statistic
of what men would do, women
would do, or kids would do.
-But you knew this
going into "Squid Game"?
-Yes, yes.
-And what is the --
-And I also --
You know, I'm older than him,
so I have an advantage...
[ Laughs ]
...of experience in life.
-Like, right now
if I played you,
do you think
that you could beat me?
-Yes. Of course I could.
[ Audience oohs ]
[ Laughs ]
-Do you want me
to know your strategy?
-You already know my strategy,
but I'm gonna
modify that strategy.
-Alright.
So what is the strategy?
-I'm not gonna tell you.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. You ready for this?
-Yeah.
-You ready for this?!
Rock, paper, scissors! Yeah.
This is the "Squid Game:
The Challenge" super champion.
Ready?
-Okay.
-So how do we go?
One, two, three, right?
-One, two, three, go!
-Aah!
-Ohh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm so happy you won.
Congratulations.
You guys were all
great contestants.
-Thank you.
-You were all great contestants.
Congratulations again.
-Thank you.
-That was fun.
The finalists from
"Squid Game: The Challenge,"
everybody.
All episodes of
"Squid Game: The Challenge"
are streaming now on Netflix.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show." Come on back.